hello and welcome to my favorites video
a video in which I pretend my desk is
always this clean if you could see the
[ __ ] that's on the floor that I put
there so that you would think I'm a
decent human being you would not think
I'm a decent human being
everyone does their favorites video at
the end of the month and you know what I
forget so we're doing it now and that
was better than not now I know you've
already left a comment about that being
distracting and I just I can't fix it
maybe you should think about fixing you
I didn't say it your subconscious needed
me to say just kidding we're all works
in progress ha ha I have a lot of
favorites this time around so let's get
right into them yeah you say yeah can
you see how this is South Hanson's
insta-dry dried nail color I am wearing
it on my nails right now I'm wearing the
color black - black is that creative I
don't know very summer I have no
patience for beauty things which is why
I never pay attention to my nails ever
because I don't have the patience to let
them dry for instance recently I painted
my nails for an event and I didn't have
time to let them dry instead tried to
put a bra on
um with the nails not dry a friend asked
me later in the night so I was wearing
something that I'm sort of an open back
ish thing if I was wearing an orange bra
because she thought that was really cute
that I would let it like see-through in
the back a little bit no it was just red
nail polish smeared all over my back
because I just I couldn't but now I can
this stuff dries so fast I even went so
far as to buy these Sally Hansen is to
dry top coat that goes on top I love
this nail polish so much I bought a
whole bunch of them next yeah he's yeah
he's yeah can you see I this is triple
sec three-in-one texturize amplifies
refreshes dry bar thing I soothing I
love dry shampoo because I hate
showering and I bought a dry bar
travel-size
shampoo and I loved it so much and I
thought I was buying that again but
instead I ended up buying this
three-in-one product that they have
texturized amplifies and refreshes so it
kind of works as dry shampoo but now
that I have short hair this shenanigan
happening I'm trying to figure out how
to do it
good there's a soundbite for a future
Joe sugg spit water on each other video
ok this is gonna sound really um
counterintuitive but this stuff makes
your hair dirtier and a good way
hear me out it basically just adds
texture to your hair without you having
to do anything so you can kind of spray
this in there and it adds things in
there that make your hair look like
you're in one of those guests ads this
is so long-winded it makes it feel like
it's got like you can do things with it
like this max that keeps a a QC kicks
yeah this is Too Faced melted liquefied
long-wear lipstick I love this stuff so
deeply I am confused by my own emotions
about it
this stuff lasts so long and this isn't
like that lip stain stuff because I've
used lip stains that you put on your
mouth and then they go and your mouth
looks like a hundred-year-old sidewalk
this stuff has moisture and it lasts
forever mamrie Hart and I usually wear
these
during our no filter shows and we scream
and drink and eat and are just maniacs
for like three hours before during and
after the show and this stuff lasts I'm
wearing this color right now this is
called melted nude I love this color for
just like normal everyday stuff
I sound like a tool but on stage I like
to use this color melted peony because I
love a lip color that sounds like pee on
me next yeah
this is Maybelline the falsies big
is volume Express Maybelline falsies is
a really great way to get the look of
honestly false eyelashes without
spending guys sound like a in commercial
for everything this is great mascara you
have the regular one for your upper
eyelashes and then it's a tiny wand for
your lower lash and yeah I hear what
you're saying that's excessive ish but
you know what else is excessive
appetizers you know what we all love
appetizers snack you say ice yeah
he fixes sugar lip polish it's basically
an exfoliant for your lips and I know
you're thinking why and here's the thing
this is a very easy thing to make at
home if you are one of those people that
likes taking time to make things at home
it's basically just like brown sugar and
honey and what you do is you scrub your
lips with it and then it takes off all
the dead skin and make sure lips feel
like normal lips next mask you say I can
you say can you see that this is a rice
cooker you put rice in you put water and
you push a button and then it makes the
most delicious
sticky rice ever and I've realized as an
adult sticky rice might be one of my
favorite foods because I'm basic a ah
next please you say ask you say can you
fan
these are ballet flats from Topshop I
think that these have been in a
favorites video of mine before
but these are my favorite ballet flats
I've ever gotten from any store ever
they're 25 bucks for 16 pounds that they
go with everything they're super
comfortable they're really great quality
I usually buy a new pair like every six
months because I make them smell so
terrible so quickly that it is that was
an email from the smell Association of
the universe saying we agree next okay
say ah you say okay yeah this is memory
hearts book you deserve a drink boozy
misadventures
and tales of debauchery if you don't
know how much I love made me heart you
can go straight to hell
this is memories first book and I as a
friend I'm so insanely proud of her and
as a fellow content creator and so
insanely wowed by her because this book
is funny it is got heart literally and
metaphorically my mom she was one of the
people that makes you cool by
association because she just
effortlessly herself if you haven't
already I would HIGHLY highly encourage
you to get this book wider book calm
that's it this was a very long favorite
good god um thank you for being here if
you like it do one of these cool things
that cool people do leave a comment down
below about anything that you want and
don't forget to subscribe because it's
way easier for you to watch these videos
if you enjoy them by subscribing than by
seeing that my aunt posted it on
Facebook and you know her I don't know I
only want to be considered dirty in the
bed not dirty on my head no I only want
to be considered dirty when I eat and
not dirty they're gonna meet and greet
know I work on it